so an extraordinary debate in many ways
first and foremost Nicholas sturgeons
kind of unrequited love letter to earn
Miliband going to turn your back on us
almost bursting into song a window into
a world after the election where a
negotiation might be required between
those two parties and you just begin to
see how it might work how they could
find some areas of commonality between
parties that are warring right now and
secondly Nigel Farage getting boomed
inside the audience but actually will
feel he still connected to his core
audience out in the country but really
the big feature and the polls seem to
show that Ed Miliband wound up amongst
this group of five actually showed that
when put up the Prime Minister
reservation poll showed forty-five
percent a year Miliband would make me
better prognostic was his forty percent
for David Cameron which is pollen levels
that are totally unheard of now that
might be a reflection of the fact that
mr. Carroll wasn't there big question
those usually for the conservative which
was why wasn't he there free reign for
Mr Miliband to try to project things he
hasn't been able to project before on
fiscal responsibility and on national
security with no mr. Cameron well to
answer back and then as are basically
housing policy discussed for 15 to 20
minutes in front of millions of people
watching at home conservatives have a
lot to say about housing could not say
it because they chose not to be here on
top of that every single person on stage
saying some version of it was a disgrace
that the Prime Minister wasn't there and
to top it off and Miliband challenging
Mr Cameron to a one-on-one debate I
think if I was at conservative HQ I'd be
hoping the audience was rather look and
that
said hey guys